Brady at Brees is the piece of filet
mignon that I thought we would see later
on in the season but when I saw it wind
up as a one o'clock I said pardon me a
425 Eastern Game three in the afternoon
New Orleans time that's what we're
talking about right there
and a man who I mean I know they haven't
handed out assignments yet but you could
pretty much book this man for that
broadcast with Aikman and the rest of
the NFL on Fox crew the voice of
Thursday Night Football as well our good
buddy Joe Buck here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Joseph great how are
you guys I'm doing fine
we were just talking to Al Michaels and
we do have Nance coming on in in the in
the final hour to Joe last word well you
know I think al got the last word with
the three of us last night saying that
the story of the year would be if Romo
doesn't pick up a check a dinner check
that was fantastic
that was good not just for his table by
the way in the restaurant at the time
for all the lovers for all the lovers
that might be that it was the first flex
of the season from Jim Nance of all
people about him getting the mahomes at
at Brady game that's the game that
everybody wants that was that was quite
he was bringing a wood last night Joe
yeah clearly corentin´s got him feeling
all crazy yeah I didn't expect it but
he's fighting for their own for their
own edge well I know this that Thursday
night has never looked like this
schedule wise whether it's been in a
couple years that I've been doing it or
in previous incarnations with those
other two guys and it's it's exciting to
even think about that having national
time gain sort of really should be that
meaningful and then our Sunday schedule
is incredible and I think it just it's
all kind of a fallout from I really
believe Brady coming to the NFC I don't
know that people totally understand that
Fox bought the NFC for the most part
CBS covers the AFC NB c-- and and ESPN
are kind of agnostic that way but I
think that when you have Brady it brings
another team and a star power to the
conference we cover the most and a
division we have covered the least in
the past and makes it really a hell of a
deep schedule no doubt about it and then
the cherry on top of the form of Gronk
which is you which came out of nowhere
for a lot of Patriots fans I mean you
know Garang being part of this too so
Bucks in Chicago
I mean Brady in Chicago to just start
off the you know the Fox edition of
Thursday Night Football
that is pretty big stuff and then again
I when I saw okay Brees hosting Brady
week one I'm like this is not one of
those hedging a bets on what what's
gonna happen in the world with the
schedule that the NFL is like this is a
schedule and this is it I you know what
I didn't even think about that yeah that
could get lopped off and some people's
prognostication so yeah that that's
that's interesting you bring that up
that probably maybe that should have
been later in the year but maybe they're
they're more optimistic than anybody
even knows or they're just gonna delay
the start of the season in week one's
gonna be week one whether it's in
September October or November or
what-have-you
I mean to just serve that is a that is
you know sizzle and steak together
that's gonna be dynamite and I'm
knocking on wood that there will be fans
in the Superdome on that day and that
you will be physically there as opposed
to sheltered in place calling that game
I mean that would be just unbuttoned
Brady to welcoming him into the NFC and
the NFC South is just gonna be dynamite
football Joe it really is and I and I
think when you look at Brady and I'm a
huge fan and I don't know him that well
we've only I think I've only done
probably a definitely less than 10 and
Nance last night said on the NFL Network
he's done a hundred games and Tom
Brady's I that's just proves you know
that proves the point that they've
ridden the Tom Brady New England
Patriots Bill Belichick trained and and
now at least part of that has dropped
off in the NFC for us so I he's got a
lot around he's got more weapons
theoretically in Tampa Bay then he's
ever had at one time in New England and
I think that's always been his calling
card and and what makes him so great
that he's been able to make it work with
whoever they give him and he's got real
talent on the outside he's got two maybe
three outstanding tight ends if the
offensive line is is good enough I think
this is exactly what Brady hopes for
that he's got kind of he's getting older
he's 40 plus 40 whatever he is 42 but my
god he's gonna have his pick one
downfield and with his mind looking at a
defense I think they could really be
good well you've been a Joe Buck here in
the Richard you've been calling games
for Fox almost as long as Nance at CBS
when he came out off the studio at CBS
of the studio and was put into the booth
to call the the top games for CBS who
would be the quarterback you've called
called the most would that be Rogers if
you just sat back and fought like a
hundred you've you done a hundred Aaron
Rodgers games in the same way that he's
done a funny thing is Pryor yeah I think
the prior to Aaron taken over in Oh 8 it
might have been far so yeah for one
singular and that's just really
reflective of how that had two guys for
the most part there for the last you
know X number of years and other teams
rifle through them so you think well
cowboy cowboy cowboy that's all we end
up doing in six of our last seven weeks
we've got Dallas at Fox in in this
upcoming season but yeah that's that's
DAC for now and it was Romo for I did
did a ton of Romo games obviously but I
think it would be either one of those to
Green Bay quarterbacks would be the
answer that question
how about you know the Jordan loved
rafting now replaying the far of Rogers
drama but Rogers in the role of Favre
and seemingly I mean we'll see I mean
that that that is gonna be front and
center or at least put it this way
behind the scenes certainly if there are
green based struggles coming out of the
gate at Minnesota home for Detroit at
New Orleans and then a Monday night or
home for Atlanta you know a one-in-three
start there might get something go I
mean he Favre was on the show to
Wednesday's he go sit an Owen three
start would get that whole thing going
in Green Bay is what he said well I
think draft night got the whole thing
going yeah and and you know kudos to you
and and the the guys forgetting Brett on
and it was great to hear and read about
because I think it was an honest
assessment and I think anybody that
knows the personalities there I just
don't I don't look there's no way you
can look at the Green Bay Packers who
you know we've been lucky enough to call
as we said a ton of their games and I've
called them winning the whole thing and
Aaron Rodgers not been the issue it's
been a defensive problem that's gone on
and been persistent even through
different coordinators and and different
personnel and then you know they've lift
you they've got Davante Adams they
really don't have a number two anymore
that that threatens anybody the the
tight end Jimmy Graham has not been what
you were we all remember Jimmy Graham is
being Jones is a tremendous running back
and then they go and they draft another
running back i I don't know III don't
think you can assess at least from the
outside the Green Bay Packers situation
and go that was it that was the
necessary move unless this guy's just
unreal and and I can't speak to that I
have no idea if he's a
once-in-a-generation talent and
obviously if you believe that then you
go get it but if he's not if he's sure
to that and then I I don't know what
you're doing with what you got a team
that was in the NFC Championship game a
year ago and won 13 games that just
doesn't make sense to me I mean
the thing that Favre kept harping on or
were falling on was what we were as well
as the trading up you know at least back
in the day Ted Thompson could say to
Favre if he did which Favre said he
didn't that hey look we had a guy fall
into our laps who is up there with Alex
Smith as a possible number one overall
selection this one they traded up to go
get him and you know Dion did come on
the show a week ago yesterday and say a
dog shouldn't be afraid of a cat and
Rodgers isn't afraid of this guy it's
gone no significance of that it's just
that you and I also know that in this
world at some point love is gonna need
to be evaluated to either flip him like
Garoppolo got flipped and that that
Rodgers could turn love into Garoppolo
by playing like Brady did to use that as
an analogy but at some point they're
gonna have to figure out what this kid
is and who he is and the question is is
why would you do that if Rodgers is
playing at the age of 36 like we're
expecting him to this fall yeah that's
the part that you doesn't make sense to
me and and yeah there are a lot of
personalities involved and who knows
what goes on behind the scenes like
McCarthy is now the head coach with the
Dallas Cowboys and that marriage fell
apart but my guy I mean even if you even
if you do the Garoppolo scenario what
they get form a second-round pick so you
know you you can't really maximize I
don't think what you could get for a guy
that you traded up to get in the first
round if he doesn't play and and if he
does play then where's Aaron Rodgers and
I mean he's still one of the main stars
of the league and it's still a guy that
can shred a defense just give him a
chance with with adding to what they
have weapons wise so I that was that was
shocking to me Joe Buck few minutes left
with the voice of NFL on Fox and
Thursday Night Football and we could go
down a Dallas wormhole here in the three
minutes we have left but it usually
comes down to the that week where you
spend with the Cowboys which is a
Thanksgiving game and and then the the
new tradition in the NFL schedule the
boys playing the next Thursday night
against another team that played on
Thanksgiving so everybody's got a full
complement of rest and this year it's
Dallas hosting Washington and then
visiting the Ravens on the following
Thursday night what do you think that
story's gonna be in that five day period
that week period there Joe I mean they
seemed loaded and they got more loaded
they brought Amari Cooper back which I
didn't think was a slam dunk and it's
funny because when you go back to the
beginning of last season we were firmly
in the camp and and basically led to
believe that we were doing the week one
game that a deal for dak Prescott was
going to get done that weekend a week
one and then it just lingers lingered
and and now you know here we are and
nothing still been done with regard to a
long-term contract and it's that's
shocking as well when you consider the
deals they have made they found a guy
that's a great frontman for the
organization a wonderful young man and a
really successful quarterback of the NFL
they're not easy to find and so I'm
shocked by that too there are a few
things that make you scratch your head
now he's being unrealistic that's one
thing but I I think they've got to get
something done and we'll see you know if
that allows him to relax and take up
because I know for a fact at least he
told us they had talked at all about a
deal after that initial weekend of the
season for the rest of the year so it
just seems seems strange to me Joe
appreciate the time I don't know what it
takes to get on daddy issues your
podcast with Oliver Hudson I've got
three I mean I got three children at
home I mean you know you know what's
going on with me I'm more than happy to
appear you know but I I know you got the
the celebs and the stars on I understand
well now I don't don't offer something
you can't you can't follow through on
well my way here for my people I don't
know why I went aggressive on you with
your pod and promoting your pod that
you're doing with Oliver Hudson but it's
it looks like a lot of fun
no you got it absolutely I just want an
answer on you at the very end of this
conversation I know just dropping bombs
I'm walking away thanks for the time man
it's good to chat be the last port and
today as well best to Michelle that's
your wife alright let's go yeah and best
to Suzy Andrews your family and man it's
exciting to talk about this isn't a dull
it is I know we can't you know that's
what I said at the top of the show here
today like people are looking at Roger
Goodell
to try and get a vaccine for kovat 19
it's just like let's do the schedule and
if it needs to be addressed it'll be
addressed but I'm kind of happy to do
this thing right now you know yeah yeah
maybe yeah Goodell and pouchy switch
roles for a week okay let's had no idea
that Danny DeVito is suddenly doing the
draft that's very impressive yeah yeah
take care of yourself Joe
all right that's Joe Buck everybody
voice of the NFL on Fox Thursday Night
Football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here